[Music]
very unusual situation you and your
sister Zoe both work in television
you both have similar jobs did you I'm
just as kids did you guys get along were
you were you siblings that we're
competitive or did you were you nice to
each other we get along now very well
yeah what happened back then you know I
would kind of torture her I was the
older sister and it's just the two of us
and we would physically fight all the
time but then I'd play kind of mental
games with her my favorite one was that
I would tell her that I was from Neptune
that I was a Neptunian that I'd killed
her sister and taken over her body and
that I was going to kill her next you
kill that you're from Neptune you killed
her real sister you've inhabited her
body and next I'm going to kill you yeah
and you'd say that and then say good
night yeah this is a repeat kind of
torture that I would do so it got to a
point where I just had to like kind of
make my eyes a little wide and she
freaked out and think that I was
Neptunian I guess when I told her I was
a Neptunian ahead really crazy eyes I
shouldn't I shouldn't point fingers cuz
I was I had a younger brother and I
would tease him all the time and when he
would get out of line I'd say you better
behave you'll end up like Ben and he'd
say like who's Ben and I'd say he's the
brother we used to have and I would
gesture to a pile of leaves in the
backyard like that's where Ben is now
and he believed it up till about a year
ago